how does one put the high of war behind
him
and his e in and are you always
searching for it still
in other things
uh if i transition to civilian life
kind of ish a little i just don't like
it
i mean it's it's terrible like there's
no
action i mean there's no you know going
and
who didn't like going to work on a
monday morning yeah it was the best
i mean and you know and and by the way
you went to work on sunday you went to
work on saturday yeah just
every every oh like some of the guys the
team will oh yeah it's a weekend
no we'll be at the team we're gonna be
working out they're gonna be working on
our gear then we're gonna go up some
beer then we're gonna go
out then we're gonna wake up the next
morning and do the same thing on sunday
and then we're gonna come in on monday
that's what it is yeah because who cares
about what else are you gonna do yeah
what else you gonna do like
oh you go with your friends go with your
friends all my friends are in the team
so so it gives you nothing so oh
that's it go back to whatever failed
relationship i had
yeah so uh that can definitely be a
little tricky
am i searching for in other things
probably you know
uh i don't know
i don't that's such a hard question to
put in perspective
i mean i live in new hampshire now and i
work 40 hours a week
i do all right but i don't there's no
you know the magic in my life is like
gone i mean that was that was the magic
the glue that held me together as the
teams you know and
you know i got some good families back
there you know that that helped me out
like friends of mine friends of my
family and like
the murphys you know the daniels the
downs's i mean there's just
it's a if you know if i don't get to
people back home's name i'm sorry but
uh you know i got really good friends
that that try to help me kind of but
they just have no idea like
you know there's one old team guy from
back there that's like from the 70s you
know
and i talked to him it's like roger you
know then there's a sergeant major
retired 30 meters back there but it's a
small town and it's like
i drink a lot and you know i work a lot
too
so i'm kind of functioning that way but
there's no
i don't know well i guess i'm still
looking for something
but it's just the high war is just like
i don't know it's
i think you could say it's
the [ __ ] best it's like the best
thing
ever you know and once you get done with
a big fire fight you're like yeah you
want to go back and like
can we do that again and again and again
it was so much fun
i mean even i mean it sucks it's hard
but it's it's it's great
i mean we just because if you think
about like
they say heroes right to me the real
heroes are then guys standing a post out
there
with minimal training that don't want to
be there and still do their job
and fine american soldiers sailors
marines you know airmen whatever
for us that's our profession like you
know that's like
we didn't even want to go home it's like
our blood and our guts it's in our dna
that's where we want to be so i mean
how do you you don't just you do all
that stuff for all those years there's
gonna be side effects
you know there's gonna be i don't care
i'm you know i'm not gonna go
i don't go see a counselor or nothing
because because i think i'm strong
enough that
you know i can handle it but it's not
easy
you know you know it's like when people
when people always come up and they say
you know thank you for serving they
always say that and
you know i say hey it was an honor to
serve course but what i really
want to say and sometimes if it's a
deeper conversation i'm like don't
thank me i feel guilty because it was
not
so fun and like you guys paid me to do
this
like what did you do when you're a
little kid i ran around the woods and
played military stuff and
put camouflage put old black cork on my
face and
played with guns and beat shot bb guns
and that's what i did all the time as a
kid and then i
i grew up and i turned 18 and then they
started paying me money to do the same
thing
i know and then they said oh there's a
bunch of bad guys you go kill them oh
okay
that will give you more money and then
yeah so so people say thank you and it
sort of
it definitely makes you feel like damn
man i got so lucky the day
i enlisted in the military i got so
lucky because
it was like you know it was like a the
square peg found the square hole
basically
right and that's what a lot of team guys
are like and that's why
when all of a sudden this score they go
okay you can't use that that square hole
anymore
they pull you out and there's a triangle
there yeah
yeah it's so true and they the service
to me i went in when i was eight i
enlisted when i was 17 when i was 18.
got out when i was what 45 44 or
whatever
and it never lied to me they always paid
me
and they'll pay me for the rest of my
life and everything they said was true
do this they go oh the military's a
bunch of [ __ ]
yeah there's little things but overall
you know i didn't have to like
figure out figure out like a woman and
you know i was all wishy-washy about
[ __ ] and stuff and
you know and oh that's just part of
whatever being a man and stuff but
they never lied to me it was always just
really really good
and civilian life's not like that i mean
i deal with people and for the most part
everybody out there is a good person i
believe
but i get mad because of the misuse of
the military now
i mean it's so misused it's crazy
grab 200 000 badass army soldiers and
marines
go over to where isis is and smoke these
sons of [ __ ]
what are we waiting for i i don't get it
because but on the flip coin people are
like we gotta pay the deficit because we
don't want our children to pay it
yeah but do you want him to fight the
war
let's we got the muscle right now i know
we're waiting for this is a crock of
[ __ ]
hopefully that'll change yeah hopefully
it will change